oh man
all right so we did uh archer weaves
body tracing and got
some snakes we started out with uh
archer weaves
which are essentially just a normal
weave
with a slight change in stance so that
you can keep one arm extended
and one arm even close to the armpit
and the shoulder so in other words my
left
close hand is weaving around my arm
rather than the other boy
some key considerations for the arm
extended or that you want to try to
rotate your elbow down and you can let
it bend a little bit you can see that
by rotating it all the way down it's
easier to
seat the shoulder blades against the
ribs and have a nice stable
shoulder position since you're holding
your arm out at length all the time
take care of your shoulder health
because of that to show this
side on there's quite a lot of body
movement
causing that extended arm to move back
and forth
and that is what's creating a
space for the poi to hop over move the
body and
create an opening like opening the door
for the boy
top and under so if we hops under you
change your arm position with your body
avoid hops over turn your body to change
and position forth so we practice that
forwards
we then also practice slide in back
two forwards weave
we also practice that in reverse it's
the same basic idea
you're taking a reverse weave stepping
back
defensive stance and weaving around the
shoulder and
arm and of course we can
exchange stances here as well
then we got into the good stuff so
trace exchanging is when you go from one
archer weave
and you slide your hands along each
other and fountain
into the other weave
sliding from fort's reverse you slide
down from reverse to boards
you slide up and
to break that down the arm movements are
going from
forwards meaning in the armpit slide
down to an x
you do your weave twist there and slide
the other arm
up into the armpit in your reverse
position from a reverse weave
you're over the shoulder you slide up in
front of you twist your hands around
and slide down into the shoulder here
and towards me
and it turns out this is actually really
just like a regular
fountain this is another nice way that
you can get into it
is just gradually from your weed
fountain to start
stretching your arms out on each side
slightly
and we didn't make mention that there
are a variety of other sliding type
things
crosser extensions are one if you
okay so just from an arch weave again uh
different ways that you can
trace the arms
so there's an anti-spin trace and comes
from
this is pretty naturally what happens
when you
change stance another trace an
in-spin trace that we work with
instead of stance changing when you're
over the shoulder in a forward sweep
you can literally just slide out and
back around the armpit
and that all happens on the cross the
side
behind your shoulder behind your armpit
so about
you can do that over here in reverse now
we're going from the armpit
around
back it looks like an in-spin arm trace
which sets us up or some other fun
stuff like this
so that's a
type of horizontal body tracing and
we're specifically
focusing on using each of these four
holes negative space areas
around the shoulders and armpits from
the forwards direction when the voice
coming down you're bringing back
behind your armpit turning your body
going under the other armpit where you
can trace around the shoulder
from the shoulder you can go over the
neck
the home shoulder and extend again
armpit turn trace shoulder
we also did that in reverse so reverse
toys coming
up the wall you're going shoulder
shoulder trace around armpit
chest armpit and you want to really be
careful here
under the armpit you should turn your
body your torso that way
to shoulder strength and as you trace
across your
your chest or torso really turn your
body
you're flipping the boy behind you and
then turning your volume here to unwind
and send it out
so that protects your shoulder
like that
then eventually you put those together
and actually that leads to being able to
trace exchange position
position
and a variety of other goodies okay what
else did we do
okay bonus material we covered
making sure that you can spin cleanly in
split time same direction on wall plate
focusing on central symmetry central
focus point
opening up and down out down and up
in really focusing on the arms or
passing the central location in
different directions out
in out in the boy same thing
going up and down the center and out
from there we played with um
doing this in front and crossing behind
so the cross happens at the same time
unlike many split time
moves you see it from the side you see
that my arms are
flapping front and back at the same time
yet we are still
doing split time the same direction it's
important to practice this because most
people don't do it naturally this also
there's what nick a playboy calls crossy
crossy uh
sort of a near far exercise where i get
even closer
ones coming up behind the other as they
separate i can turn my body
almost like throw the needle and switch
which one is in front
so left right left
right left right notice i'm turning my
body to make this happen more easily
and i can practice this down low in the
middle
up high that's essentially a seam
that you want to get good at shifting
which poi is on which side
that makes it so that you can move
seamlessly
across that seam
out half bus off and keep coming over
here kick your elbow out
so that there's room for your pulley and
this is a good position for that
your far switch keep turning and then
you're going to put a new buzz off
so i'm actually opening a bus a very
small
but if you practice those steps it will
really
clean up how you can turn from bosa
flowers can do things
other weird stuff that can go on there
too um
yeah so i have some bonus stuff is there
anything else